the first combat I ran my 40-yard dash
in Chris was the 2005 combine right and
I at the time I was just thinking I did
it once I didn't even know they were
recording it when I was on a break right
Davis just kind of challenged and I went
out there had no idea that you film that
was recording it they showed it I had no
intention of doing it the following year
but this gentleman came up to me head
coach of the Seattle Seahawks at the
time and requested it saying you were
gonna run again aren't you and I'm like
I don't think so and he goes you have to
just have some medical staff there to
make sure you don't get hurt but you
have to and I ran it again in the rest
is history so I don't know if it's part
of my comb brains of football life but
it should be mike holmgren here on the
Rich Eisen show coach either rich how's
it going is it probably win it I want to
tell you it I think that's in the
opening segment I'm not sure I'm not
sure but I talked about it extensively
yes and I said if memory serves me
correctly because I'm a little older now
but and so are you but that did you
little hamstring did you have a little
there was a injury of some that was a
couple of years later I ran it three
times I got hurt doing it the third time
I said well then we can't hair it and
may Ock insisted I hear me getting hurt
so yes that did happen
so you're saying coach holmgren you're
saying somewhere right after the Bill
Walsh stuff
the Montana stuff the young stuff
the Favre stuff comes my 40-yard dash
that you helped inspire for a second
time yeah I haven't I have not seen the
final copy I have not seen the final
copy and there is a chance you know how
it produces you know how these guys cut
things out there's a chance they'll cut
it now I understand why you were so
successful that you just shoot it's true
you just shoot it right to your to your
foot to your your players you just
you're you're honest you're upfront and
you're you're gentle while doing it so I
appreciate that I appreciate that coach
I'd love to ask you with Favre's name in
the and in in the world so much these
days because of the milestone that Brees
past and what mahomes looks like I want
to take it
one at a time what do you think of Drew
Brees at age 39 doing what he's been
doing so far this year it's remarkable
I've always been a Drew Brees fan and I
love to watch him play he's a great
thrower a great leader and the fact that
he's playing at such a high level at his
age I mean that says something I mean it
you know he'd talk about Tom Brady of
Drew Brees these guys that are that have
played a long long time and are still
playing at such a high level it's
remarkable and and the same thing good
was said about Brett you know he played
a long time and he was still playing a
very high level near the end of his
career so that's a different thing now
it wasn't the I think a lot of quarter
actually kind of had a shelf life you
all said you started hitting a certain
age and then it started to change but
Cruz remarkable I'm happy for him he's a
good great guy
so would you say he's the MVP of this
season knowing that mahomes could top 50
touchdown passes and what Gurley has
looked like for a Rams team that has as
many wins as the Saints well I think
that's gonna be a tough call I think
because of if you're talking about Most
Valuable Player Gurley certainly falls
into that category for that team they're
having a great season
mahomes because he's so young I think
you people you just go wow you know they
did the same thing with Brett when he
got his MVPs Awards you know young
quarterback playing such a high level
it's it's in Kansas City of course is
doing a great job with Andy Reed and
then Drew Brees
he's kind of I would say the sentimental
favorite if you will you know because
he's played a long time and and and it's
it's a great example of the perfect I
think of the the perfect coach with the
perfect player you know he got Sean
Payton with with Brees you got Andy with
my home's you know and you got McVeigh
with Gurley in his offense and and
that's sometimes overlooked that that
relationship and so yeah there it's a
tough call I sentimentally Brees right I
love I love the other guys but Brees is
my guy Mike Holmgren here on the Rich
Eisen show and
again Randy Reid is on your coaching
tree coach and so we're hearing so much
that Reid liked mahomes targeted mahomes
saw mahomes drafted mahomes grooming
mahomes because it reminds him so much
of Favre would you agree with that
assessment I think I would I think I
would you know he has great arm strength
he moves he's a little bit unpredictable
you know and and to say that about Brett
would not be an understatement or
overstatement and I think that and Andy
saw that and and Andy listen Andy also I
you know recommended to me Matt
Hasselbeck so I'd he has a good eye for
quarterbacks he really does and not only
that is he knows how to coach him and
he's doing all the right things from
homes and opening up stuff that you know
he didn't learn from me he's just doing
it he's creating so but I think that I
think that's a fair assessment is to say
that Holmes reminds him of breath and
what about this offense is there
anything that does resemble the stuff
that you were doing with Brett and Reid
on the staff with muj and Gruden back in
the day well I think so I think there's
a basis you know there's a there's a
fundamental basis I learned from coach
Bill Walsh and and then I carried on and
the guys who carried on a little bit and
and while they say okay it's the West
call it what you want to call it because
of the new type of style of play in
college you're gonna have that sort of
influence as well but the basics about
throwing the ball and control passing
game taking shots spraying the field
using your formations to get mismatches
all that kind of stuff yeah and then
they'll develop their own their own
thing you always add on and develop your
own philosophy to go with something you
learn but I think the basics down when
you get down to the nitty-gritty of it
yeah I see a lot of similarities so have
you spoken to read is read reached out
to you about mahomes throughout this
process of coming up with one of the
more creative offenses we've seen in the
21st century at work what well I'd like
to say it was all me
nice you know buddy but I haven't talked
to Andy
other than the fact we text about how I
was going I wish him well you have a
great Thanksgiving all that kind of
stuff I'm going to be working the super
a little bit so it'd be really nice if
one of the guys I knew pretty well like
last year I had a chance to work with or
deal with Doug Peterson who played for
me that's kind of fun it makes that game
even more fun for me so then let's let's
go into what you just said moments ago
Mike homer in his football life
premieres Friday 8:00 Eastern on NFL
Network Andy Reed suggested Matt
Hasselbeck he said take Matthew when you
went to Seattle is that what happened
well we were in Green Bay at the time
and know he said we drafted Matt you
know we've got to them late but we
drafted him in the sixth round I think
in Green Bay and it was on Andy's
recommendation and so then I got a
chance to experience it to learn about
Matt a little bit there and then when I
went to Seattle had a chance that we
looked at trying to find another
quarterback to come in and play for us
you know that that all helped because I
knew Matt and I trusted Andy and I
trusted him to get him to Green Bay in
the first place what do you think of
when you think of your Seattle years
like well I think you know what it was
it was a great experience we live here
rich you know and my kids are here and
my grandkids are up here for the most
part it's a great part of the country
you know and but and and we did some fun
things and and accomplished a lot and
built this built I think that the team
up to where it is now the fan base the
twelves that was something that happened
when we were getting good and now it's
now it's taken off and it's part of the
culture up here you know I'm the one
thing I wish we I wish we're gonna take
care of business and that Super Bowl
that's that's the one thing that but I
don't look back too much I honestly
don't I'm one of the lucky guys who got
a chance to coach for a long time and
and our time in Seattle was great and
now we live here and and we're doing
some other things that's good
I'd love to give you the floor on the
late Paul Allen and and what he did to
in any way lend to the success of your
years in Seattle well it goes without
saying gave me a chance first of all he
hired me and then he built the new
stadium he kept the team he kept the
team in Seattle so he was responsible
for the football team being there and
given me my chance and you know when
dealing with owners rich
you know and you know it's a tough
League it's a tough business because
everyone wants to win and some coaches
have a little it's it's the quick hook
at times we've all seen that my time
with Paul while we were getting to be a
good football team and going through
some growing pains
early on he always said what can I do to
help you never he you know he'd want to
know what was going on but he let he
hired people let them do their their
jobs
and and then his thing was how can I
help you how can we make this better
and that's all you can ever that's the
best thing that any owner could ever do
for a coach and and I say he was he was
one of the best in sports yeah and then
obviously you had the people and Bob
Harlan in in Green Bay what's your first
memory of meeting mr. D Eddie DeBartolo
Pro Football Hall of Famer when you
first started off with the 49ers yeah I
mean I have a lot of stories about me I
sell any of them yeah again I can I was
I was privileged to write a letter on
his behalf to get help hopefully it
helped a little bit and when he going
into the Hall of Fame but I remember a
game in Green Bay that we were it was
cold and miserable late in the season
and we were struggling a little bit and
in the old press box at Green Bay the or
the scouting box we throw a pass to
Jerry Rice
right at the end of the game to win and
he broke a tackle and went about 70
yards we want a tough ballgame
and kind of it was tough what I didn't
realize and I stood straight up and I
pushed my hands in the air and popped
some of those tiles that had been in
Lambeau for probably a hundred years and
all this junk came out of the ceiling
all this garbage and stuff fell on all
the stuff I turn around and mr. de
Barros standing right behind me and he I
didn't realize I was calling the game he
I didn't realized and right behind me
and he and I turn around go I go mr. de
Marlo he goes Mike and he gives me this
he grabs me and like Italians do it on
occasion give me this big kiss you know
a great job and I go oh those were piled
with all his junk from the from the roof
and everything that was one of my
remember
so you and Odell Beckham both left your
mark in Lambo on occasion yeah we did in
the walls of Lambo and so uh you were
the quarterbacks coach at Brigham Young
and how did you get to the 49ers Mike
well I was coaching there and and of
course I had the privilege of coaching
Steve Young and Robbie Bosco had BYU we
won the national championship and at the
time my kids are young and and and so I
was you know looking at I actually
applied to be the head coach at
University of Montana and interviewed
there and then didn't get that job and
came back and very disappointed
obviously and then a friend of mine
called me from the Bay Area said listen
the quarterback coach with the 49ers
left and you know why don't you apply
there come back out to the Bay Area I
said well shootin and I mean I'm four
years removed from high school coaching
I don't know that's not gonna happen he
goes we'll do it and so I I did it I
mean I reached out and I got an
interview and interview with coach Walsh
and and all the coaches out there in San
Francisco grew up there of course and
then they said you know bill was very
honest with me said you know I have a
couple guys in mind and and you know you
did a good job but if this other fellow
wants the job I think I'm gonna go that
way and so I said great thanks for the
opportunity which was kind of what I
thought it was gonna be
I came back to BYU and I'm out jogging
one day I was there two weeks and and
the secretary goes Mitch Walsh phoned I
told him you were out jogging what what
did you do well you said you'd phoned
back okay good wherever I am grab me get
me and so then bill Foley said listen
would you like to take we'd like to hire
you and I said well I got talked to so
yeah go on instead of screaming and
yelling on the phone I said I gotta talk
this over with Cathy and just make sure
he goes okay I'll talk to you tonight at
home so I went home and said hey we got
a chance and sure enough I got the job
so coming back to this city I grew up in
and was very special coaching for Bill
Walsh and then coaching Joe Montana
right yes that's the gig yeah that's the
gig I I want to
tell your wrist so that until I got
there Joe wasn't very good that's right
he's coachable don't forget that right
no I did another another quick story
that I I was wondering how I'm what I'm
gonna how can I help Joe is what I'm
thinking he this guy's great he's won
MVP Super Bowls and all this kind of
stuff and and bill came up to me one day
I'd been there about two weeks
it was the offseason of course and he
goes this and Joe's coming over while
you guys grab a cup of coffee and you
know talking and get to know each other
so I said okay it's gonna be good I'm
nervous I kind of nervous I'm gonna what
I'm gonna do here and he comes in we go
down to the cafeteria and we're about
halfway there and he stops him in the
hallway this is Joe he goes Mike first
first of all I want to tell you I want
you to coach me hard if I'm doing
something that I shouldn't be doing tell
me if I'm if my techniques wrong tell me
because I want this thing to work and
I'm thinking to myself I didn't I said
thanks and then I'm thinking myself as
we continue to walk it down to get a
coke I go hey listen the MVP of the
National Football League one of the
greatest players of all time just kind
of made it easy for me you know he he
this is gonna work well and it did you
know he's a special guy what was it your
perspective on the famed Montana Drive
against Cincinnati were the quarterbacks
coach right not yet the OSI in that damn
what no I wasn't the OSI yeah I wasn't
the OSI was it different it was uh but
that Super Bowl you know Danny Green had
left and gone to Stanford and it was
Bill we didn't know at the time but it
was Bills last year coaching the 49ers
and so we're in the game and and the
playoffs and stuff he I you let me I
called a lot of the games where that was
different because bill would call the
games and so he kind of gave me that
responsibility for the playoffs and a
lot of the Super Bowl and so and he said
listen call a play if I don't like it
I'll change it but you go ahead and do
it so that was a great confidence
builder for me and kind of told me
listen I can do this I mean you know
because he kind of gave me the
opportunity and on that drive you know I
probably called three of the four of the
plays and Bill
the couple and Joe audible to a couple
and uh it it was it was quite something
because he and then and then we won and
I don't know how many seconds were left
in that game but it was a great win for
though for the team obviously who called
the throw to Taylor uh I think coach
Walsh did okay yeah I think you know I
would like to take credit for that rich
but we are we you and I have always been
honest with others we have hey before I
let you go on this coach you know we
talked so much about offense in
quarterbacks Reggie White and his free
agent signing in Green Bay I'd love to
hear the story of how that happened and
what you think it meant to not only your
team but to Green Bay period moving
forward well it meant everything to our
team at that time he was a you know one
of the best if not the best defensive
players I've ever seen and I thought at
the time when he was free agent and it
was the start of free agency and he was
taking the tour if you will
I believe we went to Cleveland or
Baltimore and different places and they
roll out the red carpet and and give him
fur coats and keys of the city all sorts
of nothing and when Ron wolf came and
said we're gonna bring ready Reggie in
for crazy I said we're gonna what are we
gonna do give him a block of cheese you
know I mean we're always gonna do this
how can we compete with with these with
the stuff that's going on he goes now
well and so Ron was pretty confident so
he comes in we mean him great guy
so then railroads and I went down to his
home kind of us a little bit of a
surprise visit a couple days later in
Tennessee and we had lunch with his
family and and a great really getting to
know one another you know because he
still hadn't made up his decision made
his decision then I came home and
Reggie's a christian and and and you
know as I am and and I thought I could
do this I got on the phone and left him
a message said Reggie this is God I want
you to Green Bay and and we you know I
just prayed that he understood what
that I was just kind of having a little
smile on my face when I said it and ran
and when he came we had a good chuckle
about it and I think he we made all the
difference in the world and at the time
he helped us recruit great black
athletes you know in there because Green
Bay is a smaller community and and it
didn't have the you know it wasn't Los
Angeles or Miami or someplace and and he
really helped us with that and we change
the culture up there I think a lot coach
I could talk to you all day man
I've always enjoyed our times talking
with each other or you coaxing me back
to the 40-yard dash line and your your
football life is something I will not
miss and I hope nobody else does Friday
8:00 Eastern on NFL Network and I hope
we get to chat again very soon I also
too rich thank you thank you and I hope
you're healed up and and I'm all good
all right the next time we're together I
won't be a 40-yard dash maybe some
sit-ups or I don't know something we'll
figure it out last one for you I
remember interviewing you for all those
years that you had nothing but daughters
and even your cats were female are any
of your grandchildren a masculine child
yeah well the first four were
granddaughters so I said no that's on
the cards but then then four little guys
came why not we got nine grandkids and
then they tipped the scales there's five
girls and four boys okay well you know
women rule the world you know so as I
know that very well it's all good
coach Congrats on life and a football
life well Chester I appreciate it thank
you the best that's my corner the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience